The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
AMY BANZAERT: Hi, everyone.
Today we're going to be
doing trip prep and review.
And so the first
part of trip prep--
this would work better if
I were actually projecting,
wouldn't it?
[CHUCKLES] So trip
prep and review.
And the first thing we're
going to do is presentation.
So each team has 15
minutes to present,
and then 5 to 10
minutes of questions.
And then we'll go through a
review of a few things that
got missed or badly
presented previously,
and then going over trip
prep, and then there
will be a little
bit of time for you
guys to work in teams and
a few critical things.
I also need to talk to every
single person who's traveling,
just one on one.
It's a D-Lab requirement.
So we'll do that.
Yeah, are there any
questions before we
start with the presentations?
OK, cool.
So AsoFenix, if you
guys want to go first,
that would be awesome.
GUEST SPEAKER: All
right, so we're AsoFenix.
I'm Carter.
GUEST SPEAKER: I'm Buzz.
GUEST SPEAKER: I'm Rosser.
GUEST SPEAKER: Brianna.
GUEST SPEAKER: And our
team mentor is Kem.
So AsoFenix is a
small Nicaraguan NGO.
We're based in two areas--
El Roblar and Potreitos.
And there are four products
that we're looking at right now.
One of them is the
OJ Sealer, which
you guys might be aware of.
The next would be the Millet
Thresher, the Washing Machine,
and the Biodigester.
So I'm going to
hand it off to Buzz.
GUEST SPEAKER: So the OJ
sealer is a project that
was a D-Lab project previously.
And we're going to deliver it.
So I should be giving you the
group names, but I'm sorry.
I don't have that right now.
But it was a previous--
it's not our project, so I don't
want to take credit for it.
But we are delivering it to
the community down there.
And the purpose is to be able to
seal orange juice so that they
can sell it at a later date
during the harvest when oranges
are just so plentiful
that the cost really
isn't worth sealing.
So if they can bag the juice
and then sell it later,
they'll be able to make
money from their harvest.
So how it works is you have--
it's kind of like the
sealers we use in the lab.
And you bring down
this lever here,
and then you can latch it.
There's a latch that
secures it in place,
and that's a safety
feature, and also ensures
a good connection between
the metal and the plastic
so that you get a good seal
and also you can't just
jolt it or lift
it up accidentally
and then you end up with a
mess and possibly an injury.
So there's a latch.
There's a switch that
you press and then
it heats for 10 seconds.
You can adjust that time.
We'll have to, I guess,
optimize that time.
It's set to 10 seconds now.
From what I understand,
that's arbitrary.
So we might adjust that time.
And there's an
LED that lights up
while the rod is heating so that
the user knows that it is hot
and not to undo the
latch and open the rod.
So this project-- and
10 seconds of heating,
and the metal that's used
heats up very quickly
and also cools off very quickly.
So after that 10
seconds is over,
you allow, like, 5
seconds of cooling,
and then you can open
the lever safely.
So we're going to go down and
implement the project and some
of the instructions
that we'll have to give
and how to handle the
plastic waste that they have,
because they're most likely
not accustomed to having
the sheets of plastic and what
to make sure they understand
the consequences of
littering in the environment,
and then also explain
the operations.
Oh,
GUEST SPEAKER: You're next.
GUEST SPEAKER: So
when we were first
getting the groups in
the projects and stuff,
there was mention
of a feed chopper.
Well after talking
with AsoFenix,
we can tell they're
actually interested in is
it a different part
of harvest processing
is threshing their millet crop.
And that means is taking all
the little seeds are within,
they call them florets--
little stalks on the big one--
and removing all the seeds from
it and separating the stuff you
can eat from stuff you can't.
So these are a couple
different designs
that have been built
by various groups.
They're both-- you can't see
the actual mechanism that's
doing the threshing
in either of them,
but it's basically they've
got little spikes on.
I think this one has two
drums inside each other
with little spikes that are
just knocking the seeds out.
And this one they've taken
the tire off the wheel,
and they're using all
the spokes sticking out
of the frame of the
wheel to pick it off.
Since we only found out what
the project was very recently,
we haven't done much thinking
about our own designs
with this stuff.
We're wondering if these
are kind of capacity though.
So mainly on the trip we're
going to be getting information
about the process,
since it's not
something we're familiar
with what you need
to do to thresh the millet.
Their harvest is 4,000 pounds.
So we need to know how much
that actually is so you
an idea of how much we need
to be threshing at the time.
And then there are
different varieties.
We need to know
what variety they're
using, which will
help determine what
the appropriate method
of threshing it is.
How long they need to do it--
and they're currently doing it
by hand--
and how efficient is this?
There was discussion
about moving the machine
between different communities.
And so whether the
different communities
are harvesting at
the same time or not
is going to affect how
fast it needs to work,
because if everyone's
harvesting at the same time,
that's more people that need
to get their harvest done
within a smaller amount of time.
But if somebody a few miles
away is lower elevation
and has the harvest
slightly earlier,
that gives us more time spread.
So the preliminary specs--
they're currently taking four
days to thresh the harvest.
We could get that
down to eight hours.
All of these, I'm not going to
go through and read them all
because they're mostly very
arbitrary at this point.
And for this project,
it's going to be
a lot of information gathering.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK, so the next
project we wanted to look at
was a washing machine.
Interestingly enough, we were
kind of so gung-ho for this
that we kind of leapt through
and did the most planning.
And it turns out that
AsoFenix said, no, we'd
rather have focus on this.
So, you know, that's part
of the planning process.
But in any case--
oh, shoot.
Did the chart not come through?
Anyway.
So some key things
we want to keep
in mind for the washing machine
are the preservation of water.
There might not be that much
water to use in this community.
AsoFenix really also wants
to utilize the gray water
to do something useful,
rather than just dumping it.
We also have a couple
of different variables
to consider.
So D-Lab has done a lot of
work with washing machines
in the past.
This is one of the designs
they've come up with.
Benji is not here right now,
but he also showed us one
that he did for
D-Lab design that
was a similar design like this.
So we kind of took
this and ran with it.
Yes, so this is
basically the same idea,
except using direct
drive from a bicycle that
can be detached and then
still used as a bicycle,
instead of a bicycle
that's gutted for parts
and mounted directly
to the thing.
The key variable we'd
like to test here
is whether to do
side- or top-loading.
That kind of depends
how efficient and easy
it is to load.
We'd also like to alter and
play with the inner drum design.
Should we make it out of rope?
Should we make it
out of chicken wire?
We were thinking for a while
of doing nylon bags that
would be put in place.
So that would spin and
be their own rotors.
And then also the draining
methods, though again,
we can preserve as much
gray water as we can.
Sorry, I had a spec sheet,
and apparently my open Office
format kind of ate it.
But they're all intuitive.
GUEST SPEAKER: And
then the product
that AsoFenix wanted us to
focus on was the biodigester.
So what this is
is basically they
wanted us to find a way
to efficiently mix up
the slew based off their
current concrete and plastic bag
method.
So here are spec sheets.
Basically, you want it
to be hand-powered or
bicycle-powered.
The main requirement being
there's no electricity needed.
We need something that
stays in the same scale
that they already have,
4 to 10 cubic meters.
And then after
one use, they want
to produce about 1
cubic meter of biogas
and take about two or
three hours to complete.
Those are the main specs that
they wanted us to achieve.
Upon further discussions
with AsoFenix,
they showed us that this
is their current design,
and they wanted us
to actually not focus
on a method of making the
slew, but actually finding
a way or a method to
determine overflow,
improve their current
process, and find a way
to gauge how much biogas their
producing at any given time.
So right now what's
happening is you
can see the plastic
bags in the background,
and the biogas is delivered
through this tube from right
to left.
And as there's an overflow, it
goes down this pipe and bubbles
in the water.
So if any user were to see
bubbles throughout the water,
they would know that there's
being overflow usage.
That being said, you don't
know how much is in the tubes
until it's too much.
This can only determine whether
it's overflowing or not,
and you can only tell
that if you're there
and see the bubbles.
So if you're asleep
and it starts bubbling,
you won't know
this is happening.
And so they want to
find a new method
to determine how much
biogas is being produced.
So we changed the whole project
in regards to this, instead
of a mixer, and started looking
at the manometer pressure gauge
system of how to determine
how much gas is there.
So we're thinking about throwing
basically just a rubber tube,
having a fixed diameter
circular objects,
such as a soda can, plastic
bottle, so we have a fixed
diameter that's common there.
And we'd wrap the
plastic tubing around it
and fill it up with water.
And we'd measure, make sure
the water levels are even.
And then we would
release the valve,
so we can see the pressure
difference between the water.
And that head difference is how
much pressure there is inside.
And then we'll have markings
saying, if it's this much head
difference, then there
will be blank amount
of pressure, which means
0.6 cubic meters of biogas.
And then every day
they can check out
how much biogas there is because
of the pressure difference.
And then once they hit a
certain head loss difference,
then they will know they're
reaching their overflow
capacity.
This will help them
determine how much they have
and how much they can use.
So let's say if they wanted to
use some and they weren't full,
they wouldn't want to try to use
0.25 cubic meters if they only
have 0.1.
So this is the biodigester.
And some key activities--
basically, just a quick
summary of our projects.
The OJ sealer--
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah,
so this outlines
what each project is
going to accomplish
while we're down there.
So we're going to
deliver the OJ sealer,
explain its uses and
benefits to the community.
And then for most of the
other ones, they're mostly--
GUEST SPEAKER: Right, we can't
observe the shelling process
for the millet or
inquire into it
if it's not an appropriate
time to observe it.
And gather more information.
GUEST SPEAKER: For
the washing machine,
we'll determine which
features will be useful.
We'll look at how they
wash their clothes now
and just how we can optimize
that with our machine.
GUEST SPEAKER: For
the biodigester,
we want to go there, see
their current method,
and see how we can
implement our process
and see if we can help teach
them our preliminary concept
and get feedback from them.
GUEST SPEAKER: And overall,
just objectives for our trip.
We also want to explore a
typical Nicaraguan hardware
store to see if we
were to give them
a design for a project,
what materials they have
available at hand,
and then also develop
the relationships with
the community partners
down there so we
can continue working
as a D-Lab program
with them, and then
just take all necessary
measurements that
might be helpful to relate
to each individual project.
GUEST SPEAKER: And
finally, we'd like
to give acknowledgments
to Amy, Cami, Ken, D-Lab,
MIT, and AsoFenix.
Any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
AMY BANZAERT: I want to
give other people a chance
to ask questions, but I have
a few questions and comments.
I'm sorry, guys.
So one is, did you get
the sealer working?
Were you able to connect
it to a power supply?
GUEST SPEAKER: We haven't.
AMY BANZAERT: OK,
so you should do
that before you leave to
make sure it's still working.
Preferably real soon,
so if it's not working
you can troubleshoot it.
And you might also want to
deal into that plastic box
so you can make the
timing adjustment.
I know that the timer
was set for 10 seconds
because with the plastic bags
that this group was using,
that got them
consistent good sealing,
even with orange juice flopped
over in the sealing zone.
But we don't know what bags
will be used by AsoFenix,
so that's why you want
to be able to adjust it.
But yeah, it's pretty
critical that you
don't bring it and then be
like, oh, it doesn't work.
It'd be good to know why
it doesn't work, at least.
So it'd be good to
know before you leave.
For the millet
thresher, I don't if you
were referred Donna Cohn
at Hampshire College,
but she's been working on
pearl millet threshing a lot.
And so she might
be a good resource,
both in terms of
ideas as well as I
grow she's been trying to
grow pearl millet out there.
And so if you do end up
working on this project,
one of your challenges
will be not having access
to the thing you're
actually trying to work on,
because you can't bring
it back from Nicaragua
without going through the
US agricultural stuff.
And that's going to take longer
than the rest of the semester,
probably, to get through.
So finding out from her if
she is, in fact, growing it,
if she does have
a supply, would be
pretty useful to know if the
project is going to be viable.
And then I liked your
list of universal things.
I do have some lists
of products available,
in general, Nicaraguan hardware
stores that I can send you,
too.
But I'd definitely visit one
and get a sense yourself.
I would also encourage you
to identify other projects
that they might be interested
in, either for this year
or for future years.
It's nice to just
have an ongoing list.
And then finally
with the millet,
beyond just getting information,
if it's being harvested now,
if they have some,
doing some experiments
to really understand
what operations thresh
successfully as opposed to not.
And then also just documenting
as much as possible
about their particular
millet because there are
a lot of different varieties.
And so if they don't work with
Pearl millet but something
else, or Donna has a different
version of Pearl millet,
it'd be good to know
what the differences are.
GUEST SPEAKER: One
thing that we want
to do with all the products
is see their current process
and identify key aspects of what
is it they're actually doing
and how to recognize that.
But yeah.
AMY BANZAERT: Cool.
And then you guys were
thinking about trying to build
the biodigester sensor, right?
So do you have your materials
list for that prepared
and you know what you're
either bringing from here
or what they can get there?
GUEST SPEAKER: Mm-hmm.
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
Awesome.
Thanks.
GUEST SPEAKER: Any
other questions?
[APPLAUSE]
GUEST SPEAKER: So hi, everyone.
We are a Grupo Fenix.
My name is Jessica.
GUEST SPEAKER: Liz.
GUEST SPEAKER: Vivan.
GUEST SPEAKER: Sid.
GUEST SPEAKER: Juan.
GUEST SPEAKER: And Kurt
is here in spirit with us
all the way from Costa Rica.
He's doing some
fieldwork beforehand.
[CHUCKLES]
No he's not.
So in our presentation
today, we decided
that part of our project,
which we'll learn about,
is charcoal cookers.
And we're going to have
to teach the community
and teach them how
to work with it.
So we're going to be presenting
in front of this community.
And we're not going to have the
PowerPoint or anything to help
us with the presentation.
So we tried to make
this a little demo
and see how we can do
that to this crowd.
So we're not going to
speak in Spanish today,
but we are going to try to let
go of PowerPoint presentations
today.
So a little bit about our trip.
So in today's
presentation, I'll tell you
a little bit about
our trip, and we'll
walk you through each of our
projects, our final sketches
that we have, what we're
working on right now,
and what are some final
calculations that we
want to do before we
head out there next week.
And I'll just start with some
little bit of background.
So we'll be visiting Ocotal,
which is, like, 20 minutes--
no, we'll be visiting Grupo
Fenix, which is, like,
20 minutes outside of Ocotal,
which is north of Managua,
which is Nicaragua's capital.
And we're going to
be basically working
with a group of women called
the Solar Women of Totogalpa.
And they are, again, a
group of around 20, 25 women
that are interested in
solar-- solar design.
They've designed their
own solar cooker.
And you know a little bit about
that background information.
In our trip, we're going
to try to evaluate.
Our main objectives are to
evaluate the existing products
and brainstorm ways
to improve, so working
with what they have on site.
We've already sent them
with the materials list
of what they should
prepare for us,
stuff to do the charcoal burns,
and stuff to just see what they
have on site to work with them.
And finally, while
we're there, we'll
show them what we have
in mind, and we'll
try to meet in the middle
from what they want
and what we have
in mind and make
that happen when we come back.
So first we'll start with
the charcoal project.
GUEST SPEAKER: So there's
actually two parts
to the charcoal project.
The first is that
we're going to be doing
a charcoal burn with them.
They've actually been taught
how to do this before.
They still have the
materials from last time.
So mostly, we're just going
to refresh their memories.
So I think a lot of what we're
going to do in the teaching
is, instead of doing
everything ourselves,
we're mostly going to stand
back and watch what they already
know how to do,
and then be like,
oh, it might work a little bit
better if you do it this way.
And then show them maybe
a little improvement
that they can do.
So it's kind of just making
sure that what they're doing now
is correct and trying to
improve it a little bit.
But then the other
thing we're doing
is working with the
charcoal stoves.
If you remember when you saw
projects from previous D-Labs,
there was this sheet metal
stove that was all one piece,
and it was cut up,
and then folded
into this hexagonal shape
with a slightly open-up top.
So we're going to be trying
to either improve that stove
or come up with a new one,
depending on their needs,
when we go there.
So we had some ideas
for improving that one.
A basic one was just
to add insulation.
So if you add clay around the
base of it, kind of like these
stoves that we
saw the other day,
then that might help
the insulation a lot.
And we talked to Grupo
Fenix, and they actually
have a man in the
town who has a kiln.
And they said we can use
it as long as we tell them
when we want to use it.
So we're planning on
taking advantage of that
and just actually trying
that when we're there,
like putting whatever clay
materials that they have easily
available and baking
it, and then seeing
if that improves how quickly
you can cook with it.
We're also going to try some
other things like adding--
using chicken wire or some
other easily available material
on top of that so that they
can have not really a grill,
but just a surface on top
of the stove on which they
can put things so it's more
adjustable for sizes of pants.
We also might need
to improve airflow,
but it kind of
depends on which pans
they're using it
with because as long
as their pans aren't
perfectly fitting,
then it has enough airflow.
But if we need more,
we can either--
if we're using the clay, we
can lift it up a little bit
but have some
holes underneath so
that it can come up
from beneath and then
the air can keep the fire going
or keep the charcoal burning.
Or we could just make the
design a little bit looser,
because it's held together
right now by a string
around the outside of the top.
And if you loosen that
string a little bit,
it actually might open
up holes a little bit
in the design to let
more air flow through.
But we also could
design a new stove.
GUEST SPEAKER: Well,
yeah, so we're also
looking at the design
that could be a new stove.
From what we've seen
that what actually works
is the stove that we had last
time, the big cased stove,
the-- oh, I can't believe
I forgot the name.
But yeah, the one
we saw last time
that was going to be full of
clay that close to the middle.
And handles, we're
thinking of, because we
have a kiln over
there, we can just
complete the design of
the stove with the women.
Some of the improvements
we were thinking about
were adding handles that
would be easy to carry, out
of a different material.
Adding a door we'd also add
to increase the airflow.
And also adding a tray so
you can put the charcoal
in and out as much as
you out of the stove.
So while we're there, we're also
going to look with the women
and what is that they actually
cook, the heat they need,
where it is that they cook--
so if it needs more shelter
or less shelter from the wind--
how much time do
they actually have
to produce or to make the
charcoal, how much time do
they have, and how easy it is to
actually place the stoves where
they are living--
so if it's really easy to
carry up and put down or if
they need to move it
a kilometer every day.
Also cooking time and
they have available sizes
and shapes that we can have.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK, yeah,
so next thing we worked on
is the solar cooker project.
Now, basically we
approached it three ways.
We talked about the existing
research that was already done.
We looked into what
they have currently.
We looked into the
product specifications.
And we looked into the
question that we had for them.
As far as the
literature goes, we
looked into what types
of solar cooker designs
predominantly exist right now.
And there are basically
three types of designs.
You have curved concentrators,
which are basically,
like, you have your
cooker here, and you
have some kind of parabolic
mirror, which reflects sunlight
into the cooker.
And they're curved concentrators
because the parabola
is the curve.
The second type is
a heat box, which
is basically just a box which
uses the greenhouse effect.
So you have the sunlight
hitting the box and then the box
retaining a lot of heat.
And then the third type is
your panel solar cooker,
which is basically like a box
with a hinged mirror on it,
where you have sunlight
hitting the mirror
and then getting
reflected on to the box.
So those are the three types
that predominantly exist.
When we looked into what they
have currently with them there,
they basically use a
hybrid between the heat box
heater and the panel
heater, where some designs
do have our panels
but then they also
use reflective surfaces
inside to keep it warm.
GUEST SPEAKER: So a group
from Columbia University
has been working with the
Solar Women of Totogalpa
to develop what they
currently have now.
And it's, as Sid said,
this box solar cooker.
The one thing we
really, really want
to focus on when we get there
is figuring out why it's
so expensive to manufacture.
The Women really
pride themselves
in being able to make
this cooker on their own.
So we want to see how we can
work with them, what they like
about the cooker, and
specifically what materials
make it so expensive to make.
So we came up with
a new final design
that we might want
to improve upon.
And it's kind of the same, but
I think to really move forward
with this we really need to
figure out the materials that
are available to us.
And stuff like that.
So want to talk about the specs?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
I just wanted to really
gear over real quick.
So the designs,
basically we wanted
to do two different
types of designs.
One was where we were
trying to improve
what they have
currently, and one
was we wanted to
design something new.
And so basically we
came up with two things.
So this is an improvement, and
we might pass it around later.
But this is an improvement--
I think what we think
is an improvement--
on their current design.
We think it might
reduce material costs
and improve efficiency.
This design is kind
of like a mixture
between the curved
concentrator and the heat box.
Essentially, this is trying
to make a pressure cooker.
We weren't sure if
there's a need for that.
So that's actually
one of our questions.
We're wondering how
much food they actually
cook using pressure cookers.
But we didn't see any literature
about them using anything
like that currently,
and we were wondering
if it was possibly of any use.
So those are the basic
two designs we worked on.
And then, Vivan, you can
talk about the project specs.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
So some of our
specs are it needs
to definitely retain heat.
So we'll consider different
types of insulation.
It has to be able to reach
high temperatures whether they
need to be cooking
different kinds of meat
or just boiling water.
It also has to be able to
withstand different weather
conditions.
If it's going to be
sitting outside--
because it is a solar cooker--
the climate in Nicaragua
is kind of humid,
and it does rain a lot.
So that's really important.
It needs to be affordable, which
we've already mentioned before,
and easy to manufacture, or
fairly easy to manufacture.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah, we actually
came up with a bunch of them.
But these were what we thought
were the most important.
Another thing that
could play a role
is how aesthetically
pleasing it is,
because we did come
across literature
where they refused to use
certain cookers because they
didn't like the way
that they looked.
So that's a very
important part also,
which we're trying to work on.
Yeah, that's pretty much what
we're working on right now.
GUEST SPEAKER: Right.
And so last but not least is
the solar cell phone charger.
And I'll be speaking on behalf
of me and Kurt for this one.
So two key findings that we
had in our literature research
were just a comment
that solar is
the most flexible and
efficient of off-grid chargers.
And we were like,
yay, thumbs up.
And they gave the rule of
thumb that about 60 minutes
of charging would
mean 10 minutes
of talking on the phone.
Now, the specifications of what
kind of panels you're using
and whatever you're not,
all that can be optimized.
So that led us to one of
our design considerations,
which is in the schematic--
basically, a communal charger,
so just having instead
of one small solar panel,
enough to charge one
cell phone at a time,
having a big communal
charging station.
But of course, that
requires the field work
of being there for
this week and realizing
whether these people can
actually work together,
whether there's going
to be a risk of having
your charger stolen or having
your cell phone battery stolen
while it's being charged,
or whether you can have
some kind of a system where you
leave something that's yours
and that doesn't get stolen
while you take the battery.
So seeing how that works,
what the different kinds
of batteries that they're
using in their cell phones are.
And so one idea that
also stemmed from that
is having a port that's
adaptable to different kinds
of cell phone chargers, because
if they change their cell
phone, then you're not going to
throw away the whole charging
station.
So that's some of the
ideas that came from that.
And another thing we
were thinking about
was the design
consideration that they're
going to be using their
cell phones on the fields.
A lot of times
they'll leave home,
they'll go work on
the field, they'll
go look for food,
whatever it is,
and they'll have their cell
phones on them for a long time.
So if they ever have it with
them for longer than needed,
they won't be able to come
home and just charge it or plug
in their charger that
they have in their pocket
into a wall outlet, right?
Unrealistic.
So one thing we thought is
some kind of mobile charger.
One technology that is a little
advanced I think for our skills
right now is it's a
layer of solar cells
that's integrated below the
LCD screens of the iPhones.
But we thought that
something to that effect,
where the women could
carry it around with them.
And the idea of the solar cell
phone charger for the iPhone
is that you can carry
it in your pocket
with the LCD screen
towards the outside
and the rays just
hit it, and it's
charging as you walk
around kind of thing.
So we thought that'd
be a really nice idea
if we could make some
kind of Velcro pouch
for the men and women
that are carrying around,
and then it can charge
as they go or something.
So a little more
reliable of a technology,
but that takes a little more
research, and if they even
need that kind of
design consideration.
So some of the
project specifications
that we are keeping in mind are
the ones that I just mentioned.
The idea of maybe
having a charger that's
not powered by solar
radiation, having
different types
of phones, and so
instead of having
different kinds of phones
and needing to have
different kind of connections
to the phone, like
what we usually use,
just taking out the
battery and seeing
how that can fit into
the adaptable ports
that I mentioned earlier.
And being able to charge
your phone day at night.
We usually come home and we like
to charge our phone while we're
sleeping, wake up in the
morning, pick it up and go.
If it's a solar charger,
you would need the sunlight.
So that's the little trade off.
But we'd be working with energy
storage in the solar panel.
It would be integrated so
you can charge it at night
and use it when you need to.
And finally, of
course, there's always
the risk, like with all of
our other projects, of theft.
We are going to be there next
week also assessing, like,
if you leave your solar panel
on the roof-- is there even
a roof, first of all?
If you leave it on the
roof, can somebody steal it?
If you leave it on the roof,
is it going to be damaged?
Is it something you want to
be able to take in and out?
What if we just set up a
system where we have somebody
like a security guard for
this charging station?
And then maybe people
are willing to pitch in
if you have a more
efficient charging
mechanism with somebody guarding
the solar panels or something.
So lots of little things that
we've been thinking about.
And I guess finally,
I'll start what
we're going to do between
now and before we go.
In this past one week, we've
basically divvied up the work.
So we've become experts
in our little project.
But one thing that we
definitely want to do
is read up on each
other's backgrounds, all
the literature, catch each other
up to speed on every project.
One thing that Amelia,
which is our trip leader,
suggested is that we do
some back-of-the-envelope
calculations, maybe take that
with us, have that on hand,
because that's one of the
technical skills that are
valuable.
That's why we're there.
And so just to keep
those numbers in mind.
And anything else,
Liz, for your projects?
GUEST SPEAKER: We've
had some correspondence
with our community partners.
And one of the
things we asked her
that I thought was
really important
was, was there going to be
an opportunity for us to cook
with the families?
And I think that'll be a
really good experience.
And she said there
will be, of course.
But that will be a
really good experience
because that will just help us
strengthen our relationships
with the community.
And also I think
the question that we
want to know from
the solar cookers is,
are they using the
current solar cook now?
And what are the benefits of
them using their wood charcoal
methods or however they're
cooking predominantly now,
versus using the solar cooker.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah,
it should give us
a really good opportunity
both for the charcoal aspect
and for the solar
cooker aspect just
to see what they need to
cook, how often they cook,
how long it takes
right now, are they
cooking indoors or
outdoors, just everything.
And so if we cook with them,
it'll both strengthen the bond
but also answer all
those questions we have.
GUEST SPEAKER: And that's us.
[APPLAUSE]
AMY BANZAERT: So some thoughts--
you might be wanting
to bring a thermometer
and/or thermocouple
data logger with you
for doing some of your
stove measurements.
GUEST SPEAKER: What
was that last thing?
A thermocouple what?
AMY BANZAERT: With
the data logger.
There's a book on
the Jiko stove, which
is the stove with the
ceramic in it, that explains
pretty clearly how
to construct it
as well as the specifications
for the ceramic,
because only certain types
of clay work for a Jiko
and provide good insulation.
And I don't know what will
be available in Nicaragua.
It's rather different as
a continent than Africa.
So I don't know how
that'll compare.
I know some feedback that
I've heard on the stoves
is just a different
height and/or size,
that the original
design was designed
to go inside their
existing wood stoves.
And a lot of women preferred
for it to be freestanding.
So that would be another
area of investigation.
For the cell phone charger, I
think definitely investigating
whether individual chargers or
a shared charger is preferable
and figuring that out.
It's hard to say at this point
what people would actually
want.
And so really spending the
time asking the questions
to learn that.
And also phone usage--
like you just mentioned,
standard stuff,
is that most of us probably
charge our phones overnight
and then use them
during the day.
Is that what their
usage looks like?
And is that their
ideal scenario?
Or is charging during
the day and using it
during the night preferable?
There's no telling without
asking those questions.
And I think Amelia's suggestion
of running through those
estimations and
back-of-the-envelope
calculations that you have them
on hand to modify and adapt
while you're in the field is
a great one actually for every
team.
GUEST SPEAKER: I had
a question on that.
There's some mention in
our syllabus or something
about having a journal that
D-Lab would provide for us.
Are we going to get those soon?
Because then we could put
our calculations in that.
Or should we just--
GUEST SPEAKER: Do our own?
GUEST SPEAKER: Are we not
going to get those, or--
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, so I was--
GUEST SPEAKER: It's fine
if we don't, we can just--
AMY BANZAERT: No,
so just to clarify.
So last year we did
give out journals,
and a lot of the D-Lab
trips gave them out
and found that most
students didn't use them
and preferred to have
their own notebook that
was the form factor that
they preferred the most.
So it's hard to make a notebook
that works for everyone, which
is why when you go to Staples
or whatever there's, like,
12,000 notebooks.
So what's been proposed
is that your trip leader
has the notebook that's the
standard one that D-Lab makes.
You guys will get
subsections of that notebook,
just as a pamphlet or
stapled documents that
just has the emergency
information and some Spanish
and things like that in it.
And that each one of you
bring your own notebook.
If you are like, no, I really
want the D-Lab notebook,
I think we could
do that by Friday.
So let me know.
There's a list of
things you need
to let me know by the
end of class today
that I'll be talking about.
So if you could add that
to the list, if you do
want a notebook
that would be good.
And otherwise, you
can bring your own,
and then just start
populating it now.
Cool, any other questions?
GUEST SPEAKER: Are there
any other questions?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, sorry.
[CHUCKLES]
GUEST SPEAKER: Did anything
jump out at you guys, any ideas
that you might have had?
GUEST SPEAKER: I was going
to say, have you guys see
that portable light project?
I'm going to actually
have a little slide on it,
but it uses those flexible solar
cells, and you can put it on.
What they've done
is they make a bag,
and then they just open it
up and it becomes a light.
Something like that you could
use for carrying around,
and it's a bag or
a skirt or a scarf.
I don't know.
It depends on what
people are using,
but it could be something that's
sewn into whatever people wear
during the day to charge it.
GUEST SPEAKER:
That's a good idea.
It's flexible solar cells?
GUEST SPEAKER: Portable--
yeah, it's, like, super thin.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
AMY BANZAERT: There are
flexible solar cells out there.
GUEST SPEAKER: I
thought about that,
and I thought there was a
professor who'd mentioned
that he was researching that.
So I was like, oh,
that's not out yet.
GUEST SPEAKER: No, it is.
AMY BANZAERT: No,
it is actually.
GUEST SPEAKER: Aren't
there solar panels in--
GUEST SPEAKER: I
should look it up.
AMY BANZAERT: I don't
think this selected
chain uses the flexible ones.
They just have small
ones, because the problem
with the flexible ones is
their efficiency is lower,
but they are great.
So and then the only
other thing to think about
if you're going to do wearables
is thinking about where you're
actually going to get direct
sunlight because are people
outside enough?
And the idea of putting the
iPhone charger on your pocket
concerns me from how much direct
sunlight are you going to get,
because if you
recall, you need to be
perpendicular to your panel.
And so sunlight tends not to be
perpendicular to a human body.
[CHUCKLES]
So yeah, so just
thinking about that,
that's one of the challenges
with wearable solar panels
is making sure that they're
actually in the sun enough.
GUEST SPEAKER: I thought that
one consideration might be--
we were studying
this with the water,
I think the first lab we
did of carrying water.
If they're actually
making long trips,
that's a pretty
good time to just--
if they're carrying
it on their backs,
the load on the back,
then put something like a
sombrero on or something
and put the solar
panel on top, and then
the water and the charge.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, so I
think it's investigating
what is actually happening.
What are people actually doing?
And you will find roofs
there, so you don't need
to worry about lack of roofs.
[CHUCKLES]
GUEST SPEAKER: You
will find what?
AMY BANZAERT: You
mentioned you weren't sure
if there would be roofs,
and people do have--
GUEST SPEAKER: Roofs.
OK.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah,
they do have them.
[LAUGHTER]
GUEST SPEAKER: So that's us.
AMY BANZAERT: Cool, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
GUEST SPEAKER: So
we're ASAPROSAR.
I'm Benzi.
GUEST SPEAKER: I'm Yulia.
GUEST SPEAKER: Bessie.
GUEST SPEAKER: Adrian.
GUEST SPEAKER: I'm Benji.
GUEST SPEAKER: So we haven't
had much communication
with ASAPROSAR yet because
they're a new community
partner in El Salvador.
So some of our projects
are kind of just our ideas
and what we would like to see
or would like to implement.
It's not necessarily
the projects
that we're actually
going to be working on
while we're down there.
We know that we're
definitely going
to be doing a charcoal burn,
but other than that it's
kind of up in the air.
But ASAPROSAR has a
focus on rural areas
and needy communities.
So we're thinking that we're
going to be in a rural area--
still not sure.
[CHUCKLES] So we aren't totally
sure about the exact projects.
We're looking at
ventilation for cooking
in the houses, charcoal stoves,
and lighting improvements.
So for instance, with
lighting improvements,
we don't know what kind
of lights they have.
So these are
questions that we need
to ask when we're down there.
GUEST SPEAKER: So
just to introduce some
of the things we looked at.
We just created a library
with an image, and then
just key phrases of
what these things are.
And as Benzi said, I
think most of our time
there would actually
be asking questions.
We've come up with
a lot of questions
just to really get to
know what people need,
and then work with
them, as opposed
to come up with some idea
and just try to impose it.
But so in terms
of the ventilation
or using stoves that
make a lot less smoke,
we've looked at, for
example, the first image
is the solar chimney, which
is a hollow wall that's
built into the space that
pushes the hot air out
and cool air comes from the
other side of the house.
So I guess simple
spatial techniques
that can create more airflow.
Depending on where
the stove is, we
can get a lot of the
smoke out of the house.
Some of the stoves we looked
at were the Upesi stove
is one of the first ones.
And it's clay.
A lot of them were very similar.
And some of them were
mentioned from previous groups,
but a clay stove that usually
has an opening on the bottom
and a metal piece on top.
The clay is used for a
little bit more insulation
than just a sheet metal.
And this, it's made
with ceramic or mud.
And it's something
is made by women.
And it could be sold for profit.
A couple of the solar
cookers are another idea.
And they were mentioned before.
The two that I looked
at, one was actually
an MIT project done a couple
of years ago, I think.
And so both of them
use reflective surfaces
to get the light and
focus it onto a surface
to heat up the food.
The Ecocina and then the
other one, the ONIL stove,
they're pretty similar.
They're cast from
cement or concrete.
They are similar
to one of the Upesi
above was that they
have an opening
on the bottom and
the metal plate
on top that's used
to heat the food.
They produce a lot less smoke
and, because of the insulation,
the fuel is actually reduced
by about 60%, which is great.
The one on the bottom is an
improved three-stone fire
stove.
And all it is building--
it was a series of
steps used to show
how you can actually build
a stove with clay and using
the bricks.
And it's not portable.
It's going to be built and
used where you want it.
But it has an opening
on top, and then
usually a hole on the bottom for
airflow and to feed the fuel.
Some of the charcoal
stoves that we looked at--
and we've talked about these.
The Jiko, this other one below,
is a very similar design, just
a little different.
This one uses clay,
and it has the holes.
And the one on the
bottom is, again,
something that we saw
that you can control
the airflow by the
different openings, the door
openings, or openings
on the bottom
or on the sides,
depending on, I guess,
how much we need it to
heat up and how much air we
want to let in.
In terms of the lighting,
this first project
was actually the portable
light that I mentioned.
And what they do
is they make a bag,
and they put these
flexible solar cells on it
so that the women, when
they carry it, it charges.
And at night when
you open it up,
it uses these reflective and
diffused surfaces actually
to make the most use out of
the light source that they use.
And it's usually
used for studying.
It has enough light
to study at night.
Some of the other light
sources we looked at
were solar lights mostly,
whether portable or stationary,
something that can be
charged during the day
and used at night.
And they come in so many
different varieties--
flashlights, these bottom ones
you can hang from the ceiling,
you can carry anywhere with you.
They're all, in a way, common,
that they use a solar panel
to charge, and then the actual
light source is different.
But actually the idea that
the information that we
know about the communities
is that they actually do
have access to the grid, but
they have very few light bulbs,
or I guess I don't have
that much power out of it.
We're not really sure yet.
So in terms of
looking at precedents,
we weren't really sure
what these things could be.
But we have some ideas of how
we can use as little light
as they have in
order to brighten up
this space as much as we want.
And these are some of our ideas.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK, so
as Yulia said earlier,
one of the main problems
in these communities
is the existence of
poor ventilation.
And a lot of these
houses use wood burning,
which as you know, when
wood burns it releases
a lot of toxins in the air.
So our ideas were mainly to
serve to move the smoke out
of the house or to clean the
smoke as it leaves the house.
So one of the ideas that we
had was the smoke dispenser,
which the way it works is
the pot is put on the stove
so that as the pot covers
any way for the smoke
to be released into the
house and instead it
forces the smoke to go
outward to some place
outside of the house.
And we also employ the
use of these rings, which
serve to accommodate
different sizes of pots
that they may have.
And another idea that we
had was the smoke filter,
where the idea was as the
smoke rises over the stove,
it would pass through
possibly a wet towel,
and the wet towel would clean
the smoke as it would leave.
So a couple of the
specs that we noted
were, of course, low cost.
Of course, these
places have low income,
so they have to be
affordable to these people.
It has to be easy to assemble.
You don't want
something that's going
to take six months to assemble.
So we decided that it should
take less than two days
to put together.
Ease of repair was
very important.
In case any of these
things break down,
it should be easy
for these people
to get parts to
repair their stove.
It should be effective.
It should be able to increase
the air quality of the house
by about 60%.
It shouldn't interfere
with their cooking.
A lot of people,
they like the space
that they have around
their pots because that's
what they're used to, which
is why also we made the smoke
filter so that it was
able to be stowed away,
just for possible aesthetically
pleasing to the users.
Should be easy to use.
Obviously these are things that
these people are used to using,
and so it should be easy for
them to get used to using them.
And it should be
easy to maintain.
For example, with the
filter, shouldn't have
to be replaced after every use.
We estimated that maybe about
less than three times a week.
A couple of
questions that we had
that will make us more able
to solve these problems
is, what's the family's
average income?
And how much are they
willing to pay out
of their average income
for these stoves?
Where in the house
is the stove located?
And is it movable?
And can we possibly put
it outside of the house?
What is already being used
in their homes to ventilate?
What materials are available,
such as the metal and curtains
that could be used
for our ideas?
We also wanted to know how
they store their pots and pans,
and if we can incorporate
that into our ideas.
And we also wanted to know
what the house setup was like.
Are their windows the
openings for the smoke outlet,
instead of us having to
break a hole in their wall?
We figured they
might not like that.
Benji's now going to talk
a little about the charcoal
stoves.
GUEST SPEAKER: All right,
so a lot of the ideas
are very similar.
As we saw, they have
different features
that we thought would
be useful, depending
on what the preferences
of the users were.
And so we just attacked it from
a general standpoint of what
the general shape of
the stove would be
and what the key feature would
be that we wanted to highlight?
And so these are two of them.
The first one is basically like
a sealed steamer that sort of
looks like a vegetable steamer.
I don't if you're
familiar with those,
that they open and close.
They have overlapping layers.
And so it can basically
accommodate just a variety
of sizes of pots and
pans, but it still
maintains the seal all
the way around the pan,
assuming that it's circular.
And so that's the idea.
And we don't have any
specific designs for that,
but you could
incorporate the airflow
or the insulation as needed.
So we didn't really focus
on the specifics of it.
The second one that
we thought about
is actually very
similar to the one
that we saw back there,
before we saw it.
It's a funnel, basically, that
has a small enough opening
at the bottom and a
steep enough angle
so that the charcoal gets
jammed within the funnel.
It's something that
happens all the time,
like if you have marbles or
anything, if they get jammed.
And so this allows
for airflow to come up
and for ashes to fall
down but for the larger
pieces of charcoal to stay.
And so we thought that was just
an effective but simple way
of keeping the charcoal in and
having just a simpler design.
And it also
accommodates a variety
of pots and pans because of
the funnel as it goes out.
So the things that we wanted
to make sure and maintain
were its effectiveness
as a stove.
So we wanted it to cook
the food just as well.
Who would want to switch to
a stove that doesn't cook
as well as your other one?
So that one is
definitely number one.
And we wanted to maintain
its fuel efficiency--
not using any more
fuel than they
do right now, because
there's no reason
to switch to stove that's
less fuel efficient.
And we also want it to be
affordable so that there's
a reward for switching.
And also pleasing aesthetically,
and that it accommodates
many pots and pans so that there
aren't any barriers to keeping
people from using them.
So the questions
mostly revolved around
what currently
exists in the places.
Like we said, we don't really
know much about our partners
there, so we'll
mostly be asking me
about materials
that are available,
like what they usually
use, what their habits are
in terms of cooking, and
why they don't use charcoal,
or how much they pay for fuel.
So all these basic questions
that really outline
the needs of the community.
GUEST SPEAKER: So I'm
going to be talking
about improved lighting.
And so we basically came
up with two general ideas
that could be feasible.
Once again like
we said, we really
don't a whole lot about what
we're going to be doing at all,
but this was something
that they recommended
that we might look into.
We don't if this
is feasible or not.
But basically what
we came up with was
the idea of first a white
room, which is just going
to essentially let sounds--
we're just going to maximize
them amount of lighting,
like reflective surfaces.
So we're thinking about
reflectors on the ceiling,
having white curtains, blocking
maybe windows and stuff,
and then painting the
walls white in color
so that what light
comes into the room,
it makes the room look
lighter just in general,
because if you have
dark colors on the walls
it makes your room look darker.
The second idea we had was this
concept called the Sunflower.
It's sort of like
an umbrella that
can be used to direct light in
certain areas that you need.
It can swivel and
go up and down based
on where you want to
direct your light,
whether you want it to
illuminate most of the room.
Or if someone's staying up
later than another person,
perhaps to study or to
prep for activities that
would take place during
the following day,
you don't want to interfere
with anybody sleeping or such.
So that is why we
have it directional.
And you can adjust
how much light's
directed by twirling it
around, and then also
by how much you
open and expand it.
So some project specs we came
up with-- we want, obviously,
it to be very flexible and
to have multiple uses, so
basically for different
tasks that you might have,
whether it's for
cooking or for reading.
The ability to
direct your light, so
where you can turn
the light that you
choose to be directing.
We want it to be
affordable and reliable.
And these are questions
we don't necessarily
have a value for
because we don't
know who we're working with.
So we don't know what
would necessarily
be reliable or more feasible.
And obviously, the efficiency
of light, the quality of light,
we want it to be able to improve
the lighting by about 50%,
and has as much
brightness as we can.
So obviously,
we're going to have
to ask a lot of questions such
as, what types of light bulbs
do they currently
have available?
How many light bulbs they
currently have available?
How much power do
they have access to?
How much light does
each customer need?
What type of
activities do they do,
would also contribute to the
type of lighting they really
need.
Do they just need a
little bit of lighting
for walking around
and such, then it
doesn't have to be as bright.
Both if they're reading and
they're studying, obviously
you're going to need a
lot more direct light.
And also how much the
customer is willing to pay.
And also one of our main ideas
was the idea of a white room,
but are they going
to even have access
to white and lighter
colored materials.
Obviously that's going to make
the entire design moot if they
don't.
And where is their light
bulb currently located?
Is it wired into their house?
Or is it more of
a portable nature?
And then do we need direct
daylight into dark spaces?
So those are some of the
questions we were going to ask.
And so we have some
expected activities.
GUEST SPEAKER: So while
we're down in El Salvador,
we're going to do a
charcoal burn demo.
We're hoping to
first demo to a group
of people that are
more interested in this
who could learn and be like
our liaisons to the community.
So they would learn
firsthand, and then
help us with the second demo
to the larger community.
And then we want to talk
about cooking indoors
and find out what
they're actually doing
and if they're aware of these
dangers, talk about charcoal
usage and how our charcoal
burn would be effective if they
switch to charcoal stoves.
And then just discuss what
they use for lighting now
and figure out how we can
improve upon what they have.
So a lot of it's just going to
be investigating in the field
and learning about
their living habits
and how they work with
what they have now.
[APPLAUSE]
GUEST SPEAKER: Any questions?
GUEST SPEAKER: For the one with
the ventilation with the hand
towel, wet towel,
how often do you
plan on replacing the filter.
Or are you always
using the same towel?
GUEST SPEAKER: So
the idea was that it
would have to be replaced maybe
less than three times a week.
So maybe every
other day at most.
And as far as
cleanable, I mean, I
guess it could be cleanable
it it's a wet towel.
But we still need
to look into that.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah, I mean,
we're not filter experts,
and the particulates are
really, really small.
That's what makes
them really dangerous.
And so a wet towel
wouldn't necessarily
take the very dangerous
things, but we don't know.
What if this simple
thing could really help,
so we haven't really done any
specific research into how
to improve filter
efficiency, but yeah, that's
the basic idea.
AMY BANZAERT: So before
proposing that idea,
I wouldn't propose an idea
that you don't actually
know if a wet towel will provide
any effective filtration.
So it's something you could
look into is this feasible,
but I wouldn't discuss
it as an idea that
has merit to the people
that you're working
with until you know if it does.
And from an
experimental standpoint,
we have a capability to run
emissions tests in the lab.
I don't if we can pull off
running it before Sunday,
but we might be able to, or
certainly when you get back.
You should definitely-- it seems
like are well prepared, being
prepared just to be
flexible and figuring out
what's going to happen.
I think you did a great job
given the lack of information
you had.
Along those lines, I would try
calling the community partners
today.
There's two that we have phone
numbers for, so call them both.
Does anyone speak
Spanish on the team?
GUEST SPEAKER: Well, we
two do, but we're not--
AMY BANZAERT: Right.
But you could but you could
help on the phone today.
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh, yeah.
AMY BANZAERT: So that
would be good to start.
And then finally,
just stove quality--
there was a lot of
designs there and some
I think have more
merit than others.
And this is true for
Grupo Fenix as well
to think about, that you should
definitely check out those two
links I put on the
charcoal lecture, which
is an organization
called Aprovecho,
and then I think it's
called cookstoves.net.
Because there's a
ton of cookstove
designs out there, some
of which are really great,
like the JICO, and others
of which are getting
sold and do not actually improve
efficiency or emissions at all.
And it's really easy to
just say my stove is better
and get our website up and get
some funders without actually
doing any due diligence that
your stove is, in fact, better.
And so it's easy to make
a stove that's worse.
And you don't want
to be doing that.
So cool.
That's all I've got.
Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]